the strongest part of your argument so
far is like there is a need and you've
discovered that dr. Raj is a hands-on
project-based course where students go
from idea to company in the course of
two quarters five hundred people are
going to become a thousand two thousand
and four thousand it's very active and
interactive getting together
collaborating brainstorming it feels
like a garage in there the energy it
really is an incubator they're gonna ask
can we interview your employees about
how they would feel about this committee
startup classes are about thinking or
researching we really want students to
actually try the teams are where the
magic happens
we have students from the med school
from policy Department engineering
everyone brings something new to the
table in terms of skill sets but they
also bring a whole different life
perspective so you can bring students
together you can give them the framework
and great things can happen we had done
this for six months and by the time we
went out and hit the road we had spoken
to a lot of the investors that we went
back to and asked for within five months
you're ready to pitch an investor we're
three MD we're the professional network
for physicians a LinkedIn for doctors if
you will we get ideas come out of the
class pretty much of the year out of
this class ten years ago we founded
Hippocrates or a couple physician
friends through that as you see here to
a sizeable revenue business and even
table business went public and then got
sold about three four months ago
- athenahealth if it hadn't been for the
class providing us the forum to stage
the practice and focus and get feedback
we would have been unfunded
entrepreneurs just with another idea you
need to change the mentality we need to
change the mentality think excitement
enthusiasts the students seeing them get
to the nose and then embrace the eyes of
the trip inertia process that's
definitely a life changing experience
instead of reading or listening to
lectures we actually just sit down and
get things done this is the new way that
people are gonna do startups